welcome back to the Rich Eisen show not
only to our listeners and viewers but to
this man to my right Academy Award
winner two-time Golden Globe winner
especially for his role of Billy McBride
in Goliath season three starts streaming
on Amazon Prime video on Friday October
4th my wife and I in particular are
excited about that because we cannot get
enough of this show and you sir Billy
Bob Thornton thanks for coming back here
on the program okay you got it
Oh why do you keep um doing this I mean
you could pretty much do what you wish
your stage your career here why do you
go back and play the same character in a
way you know I I'm more of a movie guy
and came up as a movie guy once I did
Fargo I thought you know this is a great
thing because I could see that the
independent film business was kind of
going kind of tanking a little yeah now
you have the studio's mostly do event
movies you know like Marvel and you know
that kind of stuff yes
I'm too old to play Batman so I'd have
to play the mayor I don't want to play
the mayor and so you know and I've kind
of you know came up as an independent
film guy you know monsters ball and you
know Slingblade they say little plan
simple plan surf like that and so now
that's where you do it you're doing it
on Amazon or HBO or whatever it is so
essentially you're doing like a tower
independent films it's the only thing
you can do anymore to actually make a
living for your family and do good work
because as I said the independent film
business you you know they give you no
money to make one and then the
distributor is usually some little
distributor it doesn't get it out people
don't see it and it's not like it was in
the 90s into the early 2000s and now
independent film is actually long-form
streaming shows and television that's
all actors want to do it
I love playing this character and all
three seasons have been very different
and each one grew you know I mean some
people prefer the first season first
went to the second one I think this
third one which is good news
is the best one so far well I can't wait
to see it I would beg to differ I mean I
enjoyed season one of Goliath where it
kind of had a procedural feel to yes
right right and there were some mirthful
moments into it
season two went so dark well I I I kind
of dig that either was my favorite - oh
my god I liked I preferred season 2 to
season 1 and it's a matter you could see
dark as Mike might be too light a word
sometimes it went into his recesses that
I did not think Goliath would go well
then I mean I'm the main criticism for
people who loved season 1 the main
criticism about season 2 was that it
didn't end with me with his triumphant
victory that there were some loose ends
that weren't tied up but see to me
that's better I like that I mean if you
look at some of the great movies I mean
you know Bogart didn't get on the plane
with Ingrid Bergman oh yeah Jonica you
know right and so some of the classic
movies a lot of the classic movies
didn't end with everything all tied up
neatly and sometimes it ended kind of
dark you know it's not like vertigo at
the end of that Jimmy Stewart was just
as happy-go-lucky guys saying well that
was interesting you know well and a lot
of sports movies are the same way - bill
don't even think about it I mean
obviously rocky even though uh it is
viewed as a sports movie I still think
it's a love story which by the way Carl
Weathers Carl Weathers has agreed with
me he said it is he loved that is a love
story of the status with all of a boxer
right a fire spoiler alert though the
way that rocky ended Friday Night Lights
and we you were you were in yeah I mean
and and even you know for those who may
not know the natural the way the book
ended the Bernard Malamud book Roy Hobbs
took the money yeah in tactically movie
not so much though he's having a nice
catch in the in the wheat fields you
know I mean so because things aren't
perfect when it comes to the ocean well
there was a movie called a bridge too
far World War two movie not came out the
70s and it
written by William Goldman who's a great
screenwriter sure top guys and when they
first started making a spoon I said well
this is gonna be an expensive movie and
I think at the time it's like 20 million
dollars which was a lot then and it had
every movie star in it I mean had Jimmy
Caan and Elliott Gould and you know all
these people who at the time were the
top stars in the business
Ryan owned the yellow light was in it
but anyway the movie failed miserably
and you know everybody loved world war
ii movies and you had all the top stars
so you think how is that gonna fail it
failed because it was about a battle
that the americans didn't win and when
they did their research on it they found
out that was yet nobody wanted to see a
world war ii movie where america lost
the battle I mean obviously ultimately
won that war yes but that was the the
battle it was a disaster and people
didn't want to see see us lose Billy Bob
Thornton here on the Rich Eisen show
what do you get most when people come
across you or about movies you're in
where they bring something up from your
filmography what do you get the most you
know it's funny it depends on where I am
and what kind of people I'm talking to
okay different people have different
ones but I mean the main ones are
Slingblade and Bad Santa
you know it's about running the gamut
here oh yeah yeah a sling blade Bad
Santa
Armageddon if it's like especially
younger people know how that's like to a
20 year old or something they saw
Armageddon when they were you know five
or whatever right because there's the
only thing that they would let anybody
watch that I was over in and but I get
monster's ball a lot from people you
know get a lot of Halle Berry questions
[Music]
it's not about your performance yeah
they talk about that too but ultimately
they go come here a minute let me ask
you something I'm like no no no you're
not asking me that but uh but yeah and
then the artsy crowd they'll talk about
the manner wasn't their simple plan
sure sports paper when I'm in Texas it's
the Alamo and Friday Night Lights you
know so what do you get about most about
Friday Night Lights uh when people are
asking any questions about that you know
it's always a lot of people sets their
favorite football movie or sports movie
he's real
it's it's so real pretty real movie and
my dad we've talked about for was a
coach on school coats right but he was a
basketball coach so Hoosiers was always
my thing that's it I mean for me I
showed I have an 11 year old boy an 8
year old boy and a 6 year old and I
showed him Hoosiers and you know it took
a while for them to get into it
eventually they did but I keep telling
them I'm like the rim to the floor and
the free-throw line to the base line I
mean that's just the same just remember
that in life does not matter how big the
stage is it's still the same game I know
it's so good and I was on tour with our
band the Box Masters recently and we
played Indianapolis and I've known David
Anspaugh for years he directors and Rudy
he's well and Rudy hmm and David called
me said hey I'm coming down the show
tonight you know you got time to hang
out on the bus you know before I said
yeah absolutely come on down so David
and I are talking and and I said well
how many the guys still live around here
you know and he said well let's see
MERIS and I see who else yeah and there
are a couple of the guys you know and
MERIS actually played Jimmy Chitwood the
guy who married those shots right and so
one way or the other
a couple of guys came down and and David
and on stage I I did this thing which it
so funny like the last guys to get it
they were sitting way in the back of
this rock club right mm-hmm and I didn't
hear any hooting and hollering from them
and then rest the audience maybe they
weren't clued into Hoosiers but I did
something I thought was really clever
which is I got a tape measure from our
guitar tech and I said I said come here
a minute and I said do me a favor hold
this over on that side of the stage yeah
and I took it over here and I handed it
to our keyboard player Ted I said no
take that all the way to the end of your
keyboard I held it and I said how long
is that and they said you know 25 feet
whatever it was and I said I think
you'll find that that's exactly the
dimensions of our stage back home nobody
got it and later I asked David about it
and and he said he goes oh no no we got
we got it I could find it and hear you
yell or it is so Billy Bob Thornton here
on the Rich Eisen show and and I bring
that up all the time in just today's
contemporary sports world for instance
when the Giants just sat a lie Manning
for Daniel Jones and everybody's going
crazier they drafted Daniel Jones right
and I think of the scene where the crowd
is going nuts cuz coach Dale says though
it's might guys in the floor and he's a
man short cuz he's trying to teach
everybody a lesson and he holds up the
game plan and his leather satchel to all
the screaming fans like I have a plan I
believe in this I thought about it with
your Colts guy Andrew Luck yeah saying
I'm stepping away and I'm like what are
you thinking and he's like waving his
satchel in the Hoosier State exactly you
know what I'm talking about me no doubt
about it's so yeah
perfect of a metaphor what did you what
did you think about when luck stepped
away because you are again your Colts
fans through your love of Manning
correct it doesn't remember correctly
correct okay and I you know I never
begrudge anyone what they think they
need to do with their life personally I
mean I if the guy thinks he needs to go
I think he
he has a reason for it and you know I
mean obviously you're sad and you're
scared bright but the new kids not doing
bad percent reset just tore up Oh
Atlanta oh I know and and and I love the
fact that the the coach Frank Reich know
has always won with a backup whether he
was the backup for the bills right his
Super Bowl team he was the offensive
coordinator fall for with Nick Foles
right now here's the backup he was the
second choice technically as a coach
sure kind of works on all that front oh
absolutely
so yeah I got some hope there I mean so
you know I have the greatest sports year
of my life 2006 this when the Colts you
know went to Miami and being the Bears
beat the Bears and I was there and I was
at two games of the World Series that
year when the Cardinals won the series
was that that was a curse was that the
David Freese no that was before yeah
yeah cuz later on this was when
Wainwright you know was still a closer
mm-hmm you know and carpenter was still
there Jimmy Edmonds you know all those
guys and so I got to well one one funny
thing that that happened in that year I
mean cuz yeah like I said for me like
the the Colts win the Super Bowl the
carl's with a series you can't beat that
everything after that's been like you
know oh right I'll let down even when
they get in the playoffs or in this
series until we played the Rangers in
that miracle year right and all that but
one way or the other
Bruce Souter who we obviously as a hero
I assure and he he was gonna throw the
first pitch out and we were back there
in the you know in the clubhouse and
messing around us talking to Bruce and
he said I'm gonna throw the first pitch
out and it was raining that it was the
game that ended up getting rained out
and so he threw a splitter that was his
thing and so I'm catching him back there
come on and I you know and I'm thinking
I'm catching Bruce Souter and I played
balls so you know but I was a pitcher
yeah hmm
I wasn't never oh it's like when they
talk about a band it's like we have five
musicians and a drummer you know it was
the pitcher so I didn't hit the ball
very well mm-hmm
so anyway I'm catching the ball he's
just throwing it and he's older now he's
throwing probably you know 70 miles an
hour to me you're warming up presuming
up Bruce Souter hey I just asked him
like an idiot I said you got to throw me
the splitter I just got to see what it
looks like mm-hmm
hit me right where it hurts so you're
you you you you put there right in front
of the chest
yeah and then it's where it hurts and
then you split yeah yeah I did it was I
was not equipped for it if you know what
I mean
I mean I'm equipped for it it wasn't a
question so you you don't ask for the
split-finger is basically that is the
story if you've never caught one before
the last four now you're a Cardinals fan
so this year has been remarkable
especially we were talking that a Billy
Bob Thornton here on the Rich Eisen show
will talk a little bit more Goliath in a
second that when you're talking about
rivalry games to sweep the Cubs and
essentially eliminate them from playoff
contention in Wrigley Field in front of
it that's it doesn't get much better
than unbeliever hasn't happened since
1921 mm-hmm you know Johnnie Evers was
probably that's an old gen stat right
there yes but I had no idea I was going
to be happy if we came out of Wrigley
splitting it to him he's right that
would have been out of it okay great at
least we didn't go in there lose three
games not not that I don't have hope
that we're gonna do it I mean you know
you hope you don't get three out of four
but to to sweep the Cubs in four games
especially it Wrigley is unbelievable
so the Cubs really just I don't know if
the Cubs tanked as much as the Cardinals
has just been magical lately I mean it's
like the Cardinals won't let anybody
beat them right now
it's like and and they're notorious for
not coming back I mean most years when
the Cardinals get up three to nothing in
the first inning would win it mm-hmm
but we weren't exactly a team that came
back in the last couple innings in one
games they've been doing that this year
well you know nobody around here Dodger
fans aren't talking about the Cardinals
at all oh I bet zero no nobody's talking
about it I mean they're just they would
sneak up on everybody if they continue
the Brewers are on fire right now yeah I
would be more afraid of Brewers than
anybody right now
no kidding yeah all right Billy Bob
Thornton here on the rich all right
let's talk a little bit more Goliath
here now this season involves a drought
in Central Valley in of California here
so what what else can you tell us about
season three you say it's the best one
yet what do you like about it that's
gonna get streaming on October 4th on
Amazon
I think it's first of all the story is
it's a current story it's an actual
problem as going on here and I was you
know this thing about water rights in
central California and and droughts in
it that's where all the food comes from
you know I think because of that story
gives it a sort of chinatown element and
sure does I I attend to like playing
this character when he's in the field
more than in the courtroom the first
season had a lot of court room second
season didn't have much court room at
all this season it's kind of a mixture
of 1 & 2 where yeah there's some court
in it but I'm still out there like
Nicholson in Chinatown and losing your
nose I don't know we're putting your
nose where it doesn't belong exactly all
right more than that I I lose my mind
kind of in this one okay and or at least
think I'm losing my mind it's a very
sort of oddly surreal season you know
there's some crazy stuff season 2 is
that I mean you could you could
definitely chalk it up to that I mean
there were some other oddly surreal
stuff and then you've got Dennis Quaid
in this season as well who's my old
buddy
and how far back do you go with Dennis
Kwok Oh at least 25 I've known him
probably 30-something years but we go
back as buddies about 25 years do you
ever work with him is this the first
time you only did the Alamo together but
I was playing Davy Crockett he was Sam
Houston such two different battles we
had one scene together okay
and but we were always pals and we you
know we've been through marriages
divorces kids everything together and
and we're neighbors now he only lives
like half a mile from me Anderson yeah
and so that's down in Bellflower here of
course okay sure
but uh anyway we both lived in Downey
for a while then South Gate now we're
down to Bellflower but uh one way or the
other it was good to have him on the set
you know to be able to see your butt
every day they made a mistake of putting
our trailers next to each other so there
was a whole lot of people on walkie you
seen those things anybody's seen Dennis
or Billy but you you still nailed it you
still got it oh yeah we got a dog very
good we just do it our way
season three of Goliath premieres Friday
October 4th on prime video I cannot wait
I am always appreciative of you stopping
by and making this show part of your
world Billy Bob Thornton I love the show
thank you sir I appreciate that well
when we come back though one more
segment with you if you don't mind I'm
gonna open some of my residual checks I
do that frequently here and I'd love to
I love I'd be honored if if you stuck
around for me to show you my Louvre
absolutely that's next year on the
region for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 under red TV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app